UIKit is a big library.
We won't be covering all of its classes,
but we've selected a path through
the material that will give you
a strong foundation to build on.
We'll be covering, outlets and actions,
presenting view controllers,
delegates, tables, navigation, and
we'll wrap up with some skills you'll
need specifically for the MemeMe app.
In this first lesson we want
to take a close look at
each object that's
used to create an app.
We'll write an app entirely in code, and
then we'll see how storyboard can
be used to replace that code.
To begin, let's develop a way to diagram
objects, so that we can visualize our
apps' components and
see how they're connected.